Die Ebolaepidemie im Kongo will einfach nicht
enden.
Obwohl die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO
hier viel früher als bei der verheerenden
Epidemie 2014/15 in Westafrika reagiert hat,
bekommt der Kongo den Ebolaausbruch einfach
nicht in den Griff.
Anfang des Jahres wurde sogar ein Verdachtsfall
in Schweden gemeldet.
Droht jetzt eine weltweite Epidemie.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Nur hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, ansonsten verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen.
Die Gefahr war nicht übertrieben.
Der Patient in Schweden kam gerade aus Burundi,
das an den Kongo grenzt.
Er spuckte Blut und hatte auch blutigen Stuhl.
Die Notaufnahme in der schwedischen Stadt
Enköpping wurde geschlossen.
Das Personal überwacht, weil das Risiko ganz
real war, ein Ebolaausbruch in Europa.
Schon beim Ausbruch in Westafrika kamen die
ersten Infizierten nach Europa.
Es war ein großes Glück, dass hier nichts
Schlimmeres passiert ist.
Wir hier bei Clixoom hatten als einziges Medium
den Ausbruch damals regelmäßig verfolgt,
auch als das Interesse der Medien sank, sind
wir damals dran geblieben, wie auch jetzt.
Ebola ist ein Fieber, das in rund der Hälfte
der Fälle zum Tod führt.
Es beginnt relativ harmlos wie eine Grippe,
aber im weiteren Verlauf fangen die OPfer
überall an zu bluten und sterben schließlich
an multiplem Organversagen.
Übertragen wird die Krankheit meistens von
sogenannten Reservoirwirten, dass sind Wildtiere,
die gejagt und gegessen werden.
Durch die Abholzung von Wäldern rücken Menschen
immer näher an diese Populationen heran und
jagen dann Flughunde, Affen oder zum Beispiel
Stachelschweine.
Dieses Buschfleisch führt dann meistens zum
Ausbruch der Seuche.
In Schweden hat sich der Patient jetzt als
nicht mit Ebola infiziert herausgestellt.
Aber genau ein solches Szenario ist das Horrorszenario
der Epidemiologie.
Ein infizierter Patient reist in eine Millionenmetropole
ein und verbreitet dort stundenlang das tödliche
Virus.
Und wie schwer Ebola dann zu bekämpfen ist
zeigt jetzt der Kongo.
Zwar wurden hier inzwischen 60.000 Menschen
mit einem experimentellen Impfstoff geimpft.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO war damit
im Gegensatz zum Ausbruch 2014 dieses Mal
deutlich schneller in Aktionen getreten.
Generaldirektor Tedros Ghebreyesus war sofort
vor Ort und organsierte den Start der Impfkampagne
mit.
Trotzdem ist die Zahl der Toten jetzt auf
über 400 gestiegen.
Insgesamt sind in der Umgebung der Großstadt
Beni jetzt 658 Menschen erkrankt.
Und die Gegend ist politisch instabil.
Bei blutigen Protesten vor der Präsidentenwahl
wurde ein Krankenhaus angegriffen.
Die Impfungen mussten ausgesetzt werden.
Zudem ist die Umgebung dort heiß umkämpft.
Milizen kämpfen dort um den Zugang zu Rohstoffen
und damit um viel Geld.
Eine schwierige Situation bei der Eindämmung
einer solchen Krise.
Zudem kommt, dass die neuen Fälle zunehmend
in Städten und im Umland auftreten, was die
Bekämpfung zusätzlich erschwert.
Die WHO ist jetzt besorgt, dass die Bekämpfung
des gefährlichen Fiebers so kaum noch möglich
ist und sich die Seuche weiter ausbreitet.
Wir halten euch auf dem Laufenden.
Hier geht es weiter mit (unbedingt draufklicken)
dem Wissenschaftsrewind 2018 bei Doktor Whatson.
Da bin ich neben vielen anderen auch dabei.
Richtig cool geworden!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!